Ja, so kann man das sagen.
Ist dann halt eher der Weg, wie man an die Informationen rankommt, über die wir hier sprechen.
Was ja nicht uninteressant ist, wenn man über Hardware-Hacking spricht.
Nee, genau. Aber ich mache das ohne Sandpapier.
Warum das denn?
Weil wir eigentlich in der Uni ein sehr schönes Gerät haben, wo man einfach Gewichte drauflegt. Und alleine durch dieses bisschen Gewicht, was man da drauf gedreht hat, schleift er einfach eine Stunde oder so vor sich hin. Und dann ist der Chip gedünnt auf die, so wie man das gerne hätte.
Verstehe. Also da ist dann kein Sandpapier da drin?
Wir reden von was ganz anderem jetzt. Wir sind jetzt bei der Rückseite.
Genau.
Also was ich ja gerade beschrieben habe, ist tatsächlich der Angriff durch die Vorderseite. Also wo du halt durch die aktive, also du guckst von vorne drauf, also da wo halt die aktiven Sachen, wo die Leiterbahnen sind, wo die Transistoren sind, da guckst du drauf, was Dmitry jetzt gleich beschreiben wird, ist Angriff durch die Rückseite. Also durch den Silizium-Block, sich erstmal von hinten ran zu arbeiten.
Weil die Hersteller eben von der Vorderseite Schutzmechanismen eingebaut haben, die eben verhindern sollen, dass man einfach eben durch diese obere Seite an die entsprechenden interessanten Leitungen kommt, um eben die Daten aus dem Chip zu extrahieren.
Also bevor wir dahin kommen, müssen wir erstmal die Angriffsart sagen, und zwar ist das Micro-Probing. Also was ich ja gerade beschrieben habe, ist praktisch, wenn du halt nicht weißt, was auf dem Chip, also wie der Algorithmus aussieht, dann guckst du dir so den Algorithmus an. Was man tut, wenn du halt eine Smartcard hast, also wo ein Programmcode drauf ist, dann versuchst du halt diesen Programmcode aus dem Chip rauszuziehen. Das tut man normalerweise durch Micro-Probing. Das heißt, man nimmt sich ganz, ganz kleine Nadeln, die halt so ein paar Mikromedie da vorne sind, geht auf die Bus-Leitungen drauf und sagt an dem Chip, so jetzt liest doch mal hier irgendwie den Programmcode aus dem Speicher aus. Und da man halt irgendwie genau auf den Bus-Leitungen drauf ist, die halt den Speicher mit der CPU verbindet, kann man halt genau einmal was die CPU sieht, also den Programmcode sich einmal irgendwie mit rausnehmen.
Also man lauscht quasi.
Genau, aber zur Laufzeit sollte man an der Stelle noch erwähnen. Also das heißt, der Chip läuft ganz normal vor sich hin und man kommt als Angreifer und effektiv wirklich mit kleiner, ein Mikrometer breiter Nadel setzt man die auf dem Chip drauf, auf die interessante Leitungen und also schneidet sozusagen die Kommunikation mit.
Und hat dann praktisch den Programmcode ausgelesen.
Aha, okay, also sagen, was du erst beschrieben hast mit dem Sandpapier, ist es sagen, da läuft der Chip nicht, sondern man trägt den Schicht verschwindet ab und der ist dann auch kaputt. Und baut ihn an und danach ist er kaputt. So, dieses Probing ist im laufenden Betrieb, steche ich also Nadel in die Leitung und lausche dann, was für elektrische Pulse rauskommen und...
Aber das eine ist nicht ohne, also eigentlich als Angreifer macht man, den ersten Schritt, den man macht, ist schon, solche Bilder von dem Chip zu machen.
Man muss ja wissen, welche Leitung interessant ist. Dafür muss man diese ganze, muss man sämtliche Leitungen und Transistoren reverse-ingenieren und sich ganz genau anschauen, wo sind welche Funktionen implementiert auf dem Chip. Dass man später dann ganz genau die Koordinaten kennt, wo man eben mit seiner Nadel auch drauf muss, um mitzuschneiden, was da drüber gequatscht wird oder um eventuell selber irgendwas...
Das heißt, man macht erst eine Autopsie von einem Chip und dann macht man es am lebenden Objekt.
Genau.
Und dann kommen wir zu dem, was Thorsten da erwähnt hat. Also die Hersteller haben natürlich gesehen, mit von vorne, mit den Nadeln, auf die Busse irgendwie raufkontaktieren. Das ist ein gängiges Angriffsziel. Und so der nächste Schritt, also die nächste Gegenmaßnahme dagegen, ist, dass wir halt irgendwie auf die Oberseite dann so was wie Meshes oder Shields aufgebracht haben. Das heißt, sie haben aktive Elemente, die verhindern, dass du halt mit der Nadel von oben auf diese Busseleitungen raufkontaktierst.
Also wenn die dann kaputt, die müsste man dann kaputt machen für diesen Zweck und dann bilden sie sich ein, dass sie das ganz sicher auch bemerken, dass dieses Schutzschild zerstört wurde. Dann wird quasi, ja nicht, man kann nicht sagen, da wird ein Alarm ausgelöst, aber... Dann funktioniert der Chip halt so in der Form nicht mehr.
Genau, wird einfach das interessante Material gelöscht.
Also geht dann was kaputt oder wird dann so eine kleine Säureblase ausge-
Beim nächsten Mal hochfahren fangen sie tatsächlich an, sozusagen das komplette Speicher mit Nullen zu beschreiben. Also die vollständige Information auf dem Chip zu löschen.
Also auf jeden Fall für den Angreifer geht der Chip dann kaputt. Also du hast halt keine Chance mehr, dann irgendwie die sinnvollen Informationen rauszukriegen.
Aber ich meine, es gibt auch andere Sensoren, die man vielleicht nur damit der Hörer sieht oder hört, wie krass diese Gegenmaßnahmen sind. Also ein Beispiel ist, dass man sehr viele Lichtsensoren auf den Chips verbaut. Und das heißt, der Chip detektiert Licht. Und wenn es Licht detektiert, weiß es, dass man das Chip aufgemacht hatte. Und diese ganze Chipfläche ist versehen dann mit Lichtsensoren, die nur dafür da sind, zu detektieren, dass der Chip aufgemacht wurde.
Das heißt, das Package, dieses schwarze Epoxid-Blobbel, der außenrum ist. Das heißt normalerweise ist es dunkel in dem Chip. Wenn jetzt plötzlich Licht dran kommt, dann weiß der Chip, da hat jemand das Package aufgemacht, dass es doch garantiert angreift, dann lösche ich lieber den Sprecher.
Interessanterweise kann der Hacker einfach im dunkelten Proben das passiert tatsächlich nicht.
Es geht natürlich auch noch anders. Ich meine, diese Schutzmechanismen basieren am Ende ja auch nur wieder auf ein bisschen Logik. Das heißt, diese Sensoren oder diese Meshes, die liefern irgendwo einen Input, der ist dann eben 0 oder 1. Und wenn man halt vorher diesen ganzen Chip analysiert und jeden Layer auch sich ganz genau anschaut und weiß, man sieht ja dann auch, man findet, man sucht dann vielleicht erstmal auch nach dieser Logik, die diesen Schutzmechanismus implementiert. Und wenn man diese Logik dann auch ausschalten kann, dann kann einem das am Ende auch egal sein, ob man da irgendwas versteht.
Das Problem ist, normalerweise kann man es halt nicht ausschalten, weil man erst durch das Mesh durchgehen muss von vorne. Aber jetzt kommen wir tatsächlich zur Rückseite.
Genau.
Eine Frage noch sozusagen. Also A, das ist Interesse an den Chips und B, diese Sicherheitsmaßnahmen. Ist das jetzt bei allen Chips, die so überwägt sind? Also, keine Ahnung, der Prozessor an meinem Rechner, hat der sowas? Oder ist das wirklich Vorbehalt so ganz speziellen Chips?
Interessanterweise sind die alle sichersten Chips, die man auf dem Markt kaufen kann, diese blöde PTV-Karten, die man hat, die sind wesentlich sicherer, also die haben, wenn man die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen anschaut, dann haben die wesentlich mehr Sicherheitsmaßnahmen, als jeder Arm-System-on-Chip, der in seinem Smartphone ist oder sein Intel-Prozessor. Die haben da eigentlich gar keine Maßnahmen, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass der Chip viel zu hoch komplex ist, dass jemand sich sozusagen die Mühe geben würde, tatsächlich Transistor für Transistor da durchzugehen und die interessanten Informationen zu holen.
Und auch eigentlich viel zu uninteressant, weil tatsächlich 100% des interessanten Informationsgehalts kommt aus der Software, die auf dem Prozessor läuft.
Und die PTV-Branche hat schon sehr viel Geld verloren und die haben natürlich eine Motivation, da auch Research zu stellen.
Und wir müssen das ein bisschen zu quantifizieren, also ihr wisst, das eine, also ich meine, das sind so in den USA, ist das die 11. oder 12. Generation von PTV-Karten. Und alle Generationen zuvor wurden gehackt. Also das heißt, sie müssen 11-mal neue Chips entwickeln, bevor sie eins gefunden haben, was jetzt einige Jahre überlebt hatte.
Wie waren vorher so die Halbwert-Zeiten?
Ja, also da gab es schon sehr schlecht, also es gab verschiedene Hacks, ja. Also es gibt vielleicht nur, weil die PTV-Branche so eine lebendige Geschichte hatte, sollte man auch, also es gab auch diese Software-Bugs, da gab es, man kann die Karten tatsächlich über sozusagen die Funkverbindung, also über Satellit auch patchen. Beziehungsweise man kann, was die PTV-Industrie auch tut, ist, dass sie patchen ihre eigenen Karten und sie reverse-ingenieren die Karten, die die Piraten selber nachgebaut hatte. Und da gibt es sehr viele Geschichten, wie entweder tatsächlich Patches ohne die Karten auszutauschen, also sozusagen ein Update kam over the air, wie man das nennt, also über die Funkstrecke kam ein Update und die Karte hat diese Schwachstelle irgendwie nicht mehr, also durch dieses Update gab es diese Schwachstelle nicht mehr, aber was auch eine sehr große Industrie ist in der PTV-Branche, ist, dass sozusagen Hacker auf Seite des Content-Anbieters bezahlt werden, um Fehler in der Software-Implementierung von den Piratenkarten zu finden, damit sie sozusagen über die Funkstrecke eine Malware, also ein Virus, oder irgendein Exploit, der die Karte ausschaltet, auf die man in bestimmten Zeiten kommt. Und da gab es sehr viele Geschichten, zum Beispiel in den USA hieß es Black Friday oder Black Thursday, ich vergesse immer, wann die Super Bowl gespielt wird, aber jedenfalls war das, oder ne, Sunday müsste das sein, Fußball wird ja immer an Sunday gespielt, aber jedenfalls gab es da so ein schwarzer Tag für die ganzen Leute, die Piraten sind, und dann haben sie tatsächlich fünf Minuten bevor die Super Bowl angefangen hat, hat einer der großen Content-Anbieter sozusagen das letzte Stück von diesem Software, also von diesem Exploit runtergeschickt, so dass alle Piratenkarten ausgeschaltet wurden.
Also eigentlich ökonomisch voll umklugt, das hätte man Samstagnachmittag machen müssen.
Dann hätten nämlich die Leute schnell noch eine neue Karte gekauft.
Okay, da hatten Leute anscheinend viel Spaß. Kehren wir zurück zum Angriff auf den Chip. Also wir haben gerade festgestellt, den Chip kann man von oben sozusagen einmal aufschleifen angucken, dann kann man mit den Nadeln reinstechen und da gibt es den Sicherheitsmechanismen, deswegen geht man jetzt von unten quasi ran.
Genau, also eigentlich sind heutzutage, also alle Mechanismen, die bis heute entwickelt worden sind, gehen eigentlich davon aus, dass der Angreifer von der aktiven Seite des Chips angreift. Das heißt, dass der Angreifer, also wie Starbucks schon sagte, auf der Seite, wo die Transistoren an alle Verbindungen sind.
Nur für unser Verständnis, also ich kenne den Chip so, es gibt eine Leiterplatte, da ist ein Chip drauf und da ist es oben schwarz. Was ist da jetzt oben und unten?
Wir reden von dem Silizium-Ding, was in dem schwarzen Teil drin ist.
Das müsst ihr vielleicht dazu sagen.
Ja, also wenn man eine Intel-Werbung gesehen hat, dann hat man viele Inder gesehen, die da rumlaufen mit großem sogenannten Wafer. Also das sind so große Scheiben, auf denen tatsächlich was glänzt. Ja, und es glänzt nicht gleichmäßig und es glänzt für die menschliche Auge nicht gleichmäßig, weil da tatsächlich irgendwelche Strukturen angebracht worden sind.
Also die Leiterbahnen.
Genau, die Leiterbahnen und die sozusagen darunter sind die Transistoren. Aber was man in der Regel tut, um einen Hype-Leiter zu produzieren, ist, man nimmt eine Seite, ist egal wie, ist ein homogenes Material, sozusagen was man davor hat, also ein gleichmäßiges Material. Und man fängt an, auf einer dieser Seiten sozusagen Material anwachsen zu lassen, indem man das chemisch auf die Oberfläche dampft.
Also diese verschiedenen Schichten.
Also die Leiterbahnen, genau.
Genau, die Leiterbahnen und auch die Wells, um die Transistoren herzustellen.
Und das jetzt ist die Oberseite. Und oben ist, man guckt von oben drauf, also auf die letzte Schicht, die aufgedampft wurde.
Genau, weil das ist auch für die Logik ist die entscheidende, also ist entscheiden, wie die Verbindungen sind. Also schaut man sich eigentlich, in der Regel schaut man sich das Ganze von der Frontside, also von oben an.
Genau, und wenn du sagst, du kommst von unten, dann ist das quasi das Küchenbrett, auf dem das ganze Zeug aufgehört ist? Genau.
Also durch das ganze Silizium erst mal durchgegraben und dann kommt man faktisch von unten an die Transistoren und dann nach die Fahrtratungsleiterbahnen.
Und ich bin eigentlich, sollte ich vielleicht auch erwähnt haben, ich bin auch Doktorand an der TU Berlin bei Herrn Prof. Seifert in Security and Telecommunications. Und meine Doktorarbeit besteht darin, dass wir uns neue Wege ausgedacht haben, wie wir alle Sicherheitsmaßnahmen umgehen können, die heutzutage auf dem Chip sind. Und das Nahliegendste war, wir drehen den Chip um und gehen von der anderen Seite. Weil da gibt es weder diese Schutzschichten, noch die ganzen Sensoren.
Das war wirklich alles. Sie haben einfach nur den Chip umgedreht.
Dafür kriegt man in Deutschland einen Dr. Tieter.
Moment mal. Muss man wirklich gar nichts weiter machen?
Doch, da war ziemlich viel Arbeit darin, wie man die Stelle wiederum, wenn man das Ganze umgedreht hat, wie man die richtige Stelle findet und was man da alles tun kann.
Also Präparierung erst mal, du musst ja erst mal hinkommen, das irgendwie runterpolieren oder runterätzen, runterschleifen.
Genau, also der Rad musste, zwar ist da vieles dabei, aber schon musste irgendwie der Rad neu entwickelt werden, um das zu machen. Also ich will das nicht so sagen, als wenn es so trivial ist, aber ist schon erstaunlich.
Also Dmitry hat seinen Dr. Tieter dann auch wirklich verdient, wenn er ihn hat.
Aber auf der abstrakten Ebene ist es schon so, die clever Idee war, das Ding einfach umzudrehen und dann war die Fleißarbeit sozusagen zu realisieren, wie man das so gemacht hat.
Genau, also die Methoden, die bisher existiert haben, so anzupassen, dass sie auch für die Rückseite funktionieren.
Und natürlich auch neue Methoden zu finden, die halt jetzt durch die Vorderseite nicht mehr gehen.
Genau, also das war alles Thema in meinem Talk. Aber um vielleicht das Ganze so auf den oder in einem Satz zusammenzufassen, eigentlich, was man, man hat sich, wenn man vor allem die Literatur, die wissenschaftliche Literatur dazu anschaut von vor vielen Jahren, haben viele gedacht, dass das alles unmöglich ist. Und das war umso mehr sozusagen, das war erstaunlich, wie einfach das eigentlich ist und was für eine große Bedrohung, das eigentlich für die ganze Industrie ist, weil sie sind darauf völlig unvorbereitet.
Also wie erschreckend ist, es gibt doch tatsächlich nicht wirklich eine Möglichkeit, da jetzt Gegenmaßnahmen zu initialisieren. Also bei der Vorderseite, da gab es halt irgendwie, da macht es halt irgendwie Meshes oder Sensoren. Da kann man sich halt alle möglichen sinnvollen Sachen vorstellen, weil der Rückseite ist halt tatsächlich sehr schwierig, sich auch nur, also wir haben natürlich auch darüber nachgedacht, wie kann man das jetzt irgendwie verhindern, dass wir das tun? Und so richtig coole Ideen hatten wir einfach nicht gehabt.
Um das kurz zusammenzufassen, eigentlich funktioniert der Chip nur, also die Halbleiter, die Chips, werden so hergestellt, dass da tatsächlich nur auf eine Seite sozusagen Material anwächst. Und da gibt es keine Möglichkeit, den Chip umzudrehen und auf der anderen Seite einfach was anwachsen zu lassen. Da gibt es ein paar Ansätze, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das entweder viel zu teuer, weil das den Preis für jeden Chip mehr als verdoppelt, oder das ist einfach nicht realisierbar mit den heutigen Herstellungsmethoden.
Also ich finde ja, wir sollten tatsächlich mal so ein paar Beispiele von diesen Rückseitenangriffen hier mal zu Gute tun. Also ich würde einfach mal, also ich meine, so der Probing haben wir ja schon gesagt, irgendwie das ging halt normalerweise durch die Vorderseite heutzutage. Dann nimmst du halt, also tatsächlich von der Rückseite nimmst halt das ein Fokus einbeam. Also das ist irgendwie so das Gerät, was man als Chip-Hacker heutzutage haben muss.
Das ist ein Fokussiertes Ionenbündel.
Jetzt fühle ich mich wie bei Star Wars.
Das ist auch total Star Wars.
Wie teuer ist sowas?
Das ist ganz schön teuer, also bist du da schon so im Millionen, also so sechsstelligen, siebenstelligen Bereichen zwischen?
Nein, nein, es hängt aber dabei so, ich würde sagen, das hängt schon bei 250.000 an, aber trotzdem ist man...
Der Betrieb selbst ist aber auch ziemlich teuer. Also die Gase und Chemikalien, die man dafür braucht, die sind auch nicht ohne.
Also unabhängig davon, wie teuer die Anschaffungskosten sind, hast du immer die Möglichkeit, für relativ wenig Geld, dir stundenweise oder tageweise dieses Gerät zu leihen. Von daher ist es halt gar nicht so schlimm jetzt, dass es teuer ist. Du kannst halt immer noch mit relativ geringen Kosten diese Angriffe durchführen. Also was man halt tut ist, was wir gerade gesagt haben, man bohrt halt praktisch von hinten durch das Lithium durch, mit diesem Fokuseinbeam, einfach gesprochen, bis man halt an den Transistoren und den Leiterbahnen ist. Und dann kann man sie theoretisch kontaktieren. Das Problem ist halt nun, dass man halt relativ weit gebohrt hat. Das heißt, man muss jetzt irgendwie erst mal diese Leitungen wieder nach draußen verlegen.
Also man muss an dieser Stelle sozusagen vollständig die, also sozusagen von der Gesamtdicke des Chips muss man so circa 98 Prozent entfernen.
Okay, krass.
Also was man tut, man muss halt diese Leiterbahnen irgendwie so weit nach außen wiederbringen, dass man sie dann kontaktieren kann wieder mit den Nadeln. Und dafür, was das Tolle an diesem Fokus einbeben ist, dass es nicht nur Material abtragen kann, sondern auch Material wieder hinzufügen kann. Das heißt, du kannst dann sehr wohl auch Leitendes oder nicht Leitendes Material wieder, also du hast ja dieses Loch, was irgendwie unter auf die Leiterbahn geht und dann schmeißt du halt um ganz viel Wolfram in dieses Loch, also Leitendes Material und füllst es praktisch leitend auf und kannst dann oben auf das Ende vom Loch dann wieder den Nadel setzen und praktisch dem Chip wieder beim Arbeiten.
Also du kannst sozusagen auch diese Verbindung sehr viel, sehr viel größer machen. Also obwohl die sozusagen dieses, dieses Loch, was man durchbohren muss, bis man, bis man an den Transistoren und Leiterbahnen kommt, ankommt, obwohl das sozusagen wirklich in Nanometerbereich sein wird, kann man das wirklich, indem man dann leidfähiges Material abscheidet und eine Verbindung sozusagen nach oben, also in dem Fall weit nach unten zieht, kann man, kann man dann sich diese, also ist es realistisch. Also man kann mit solchen Angriffen tatsächlich auch die neuste Technologien, also die neuste Chips angreifen, die sowas wie 22 Nanometer sind. Man muss nur die passende Gerätschaften dazu haben, die einer dieser Arbeiten möglichen.
Okay, jetzt sagen wir mal, abgesehen von PayTV-Karten, wo ist denn sowas noch interessant?
Die Hüsteltaste. Also zum Beispiel Indikationsdokumente, also E-Pass, E-Perso, da zum Beispiel. Oder Wegversperren, also überall, wo halt mit Sicherheit und Microchips gearbeitet wird, Zugangskarten, also in allen Bereichen.
Okay, würdet ihr sagen, das ist auch auf eine Art und Weise realisierbar, dass man, dass das also jemand, der Interesse daran hat, das wirklich sozusagen für sich auch organisieren kann? Also ihr habt gerade gesagt, irgendwie teures Gret, man kann es aber irgendwie mieten, also ist das jetzt so ein jedermanns Ding oder seid irgendwie Starbucks, Dmitry und Thorsten, genau die drei Leute in Deutschland, die sowas können?
Also es können tatsächlich nicht so wirklich viele, aber wenn jemand Interesse hat, dann kann er schon mit, keine Ahnung, ein bisschen Aufwand, also ein bisschen finanziellen Aufwand beziehungsweise so als Uni, so als Diplomarbeit oder Dissertation auf jeden Fall ist das irgendwie ohne Probleme möglich, das zu machen.
Liegt halt an deiner Motivation, was willst du erreichen? Also ich denke, man kann das gar nicht genau sagen, wie viele Leute es eigentlich gibt, die diese Möglichkeit haben, denn ich würde mal vermuten, dass die meisten, die diese Möglichkeit haben, damit nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gehen, weil sie damit nämlich auf dem Schwarzmarkt Geld verdienen am Ende.
Aber was passiert denn zum Beispiel, wenn man, keine Ahnung, so einen Personalausweis dann irgendwie aufmacht und weiß, was da drin ist? Was kann man dann damit machen?
Na du kannst den Key extrahieren, der sicherstellt, dass die Bundesdruckerei diesen Ausweis ausgestellt hat. Das heißt, du kannst dir deinen eigenen Ausweis ausstellen, mit deinen Finger abdrücken, mit deinem Bild und der sieht halt für jedes Lesegerät aus wie ein echter Ausweis. Also er ist offiziell ein echter Ausweis. Und naja, ich meine, heutzutage für Ausweisdokumente in Deutschland zahlt man knappe 10.000 Euro, also gefälschte. Von daher kann man da schon durchaus Geld mitmachen. Und da ist halt auch wieder keine Frage, dass man irgendwie jetzt mal für zwei Tage sich so ein FIP mietet, was dann irgendwie dann 2.000 Euro kostet am Tag, weil du halt mit einem verkauften Dokument das Geld locker wieder drin hast.
Und das Schlimme an diesen Dingern ist ja, dass von allen Stellen, also vom Hersteller, von den Politikern und allen Leuten, die das Ganze befürworten, suggeriert wird, dass alleine durch diesen Chip, diesen Sicherheitschip, der da drin ist, ist dieser Ausweis nicht zu fälschen, nicht zu klonen und macht alles sicherer. Und am Ende, ich meine, am Ende kann man möglicherweise doch diesen Ausweis klonen. Und zwar wird das eben gerade genau dadurch begünstigt, dass da eben Digitaltechnik mit drin steckt, auf die man sich dann eben blind verlässt. Weil alle sagen, man kann sich und muss sich auch blind darauf verlassen.
Das sind einmalige Kosten, von denen wir hier reden. Das machst du einmal, das macht irgendjemand auf der Welt einmal extra diesen Key. Und wenn er diese Informationen freigibt, kann halt jeder Arsch sich einen Ausweis machen.
Ja, also es ist wirklich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt, der auf jeden Fall klar rüberkommen muss. Also man hat diese Kosten nur einmal und jeder weitere Ausweis, den man dann vielleicht klonen will, hat halt weniger hohe Kosten zufolge. Das geht dann halt später einfacher.
Das ist dann im Bereich ein paar Tausend Euro.
Na ja, ein paar hundert. Also ich streite gerade über die Aufmachkosten, aber der wichtige Punkt ist, den man als auch wie so ein Nebenbeilern-Effekt, den wir heute hier haben, ist, dass das Problem mit dem E-Perso zum Beispiel ist, es ist in der Tat aufwendiger geworden, so ein Ding zu fälschen, weil ich brauche jetzt für 2000 Euro im Tag einmal so ein Gerät. Aber weil sich die Leute viel mehr drauf verlassen, weil ihnen ja gesagt wurde, das ist ein Chip drin, das ist alles sicher, ist die Fälschungsgefahr eigentlich größer als vorher?
Also der Grenzbeamte guckt jetzt auf die grüne Lampe, die sagt, dieser Chip ist valide, der Ausweis ist damit gültig.
Genau, der Kunde guckt nicht mehr auf das UV-Abstrahl.
Genau, also früher hat der irgendwie angeguckt, ob das Bild übereinstimmt, ob da die ganzen Sicherheitsmerkmale auf dem Pass irgendwie stimmen. Heutzutage ist die grüne Lampe an, alles klar.
Okay, wir haben noch einen Anrufer, der Michael, der hat, glaube ich, tatsächlich auch eine Frage genau zu dem Perso. Hallo Micha.
Ja, naja, gut, dass wir gerade auf das Thema kommen. Als damals der elektronische Personalausweis rauskam, hat der Chaos Computer Club sich damit befasst und gezeigt, dass man diesen RFID-Ship kontaktlos auflesen kann, mit Fingerdrücken ein, um und dran, um den Unfug treiben kann. Und dann könnte man seinen Fingerdruckofen oder Mordswaffe irgendwann wieder finden. Jetzt ist meine Frage, was hat sich da in der Zwischenzeit getan? Ist da was sicherer geworden, beziehungsweise wie kann ich mich gegen das Auslesen schützen?
Also, die Fingerabdrücke konntest du noch nie auslesen. Die sind tatsächlich geschützt mit PKIs, also mit irgendwie kryptographischen Varianten. Wenn du allerdings das, was wir gerade beschrieben haben, diesen Chip einmal irgendwie aufmachst, dann kannst du sehr wohl auch die Fingerabdrücke auslesen. Und dann kannst du diese Fingerabdrücke auch sehr wohl nachbilden und auf eine Mordswaffe platzieren. Aber da gibt es natürlich auch viel einfache Möglichkeiten, um an Fingerabdrücke zu kommen.
Also das ist noch nicht passiert, aber das wäre eine Gefahr.
Den Ausweis selber, ich meine, den hat man ja auch mal in der Haustasse.
Okay, also aber an der Sicherheitsarchitektur hat sich seit Erscheinen des E-Persos nichts geändert.
Also sie haben, glaube ich, inzwischen eine neue Chip-Generation, aber die nicht explizit auf irgendwelche Schwachstellen, also wegen Schwachstellen umgestellt wurde, sondern weil inzwischen schon fast 10 Jahre vergangen sind.
Aber man soll vielleicht an der Stelle auch erwähnen, wie das wirklich funktioniert. Also wenn ein Hersteller eine Chip-Karte ist, dann muss man durch einen staatlichen Zertifizierungsverfahren durch mit seinem Produkt. Also man hat seine Karte, also man hat seinen Chip hergestellt, was in ein E-Perso kommt, und in Deutschland wird das dann vom BSI über ein sogenanntes Common Criteria Verfahren zertifiziert. Und was auch zeigt für mich, wie kaputt Zertifizierung an sich ist, ist, dass einer der Kriterien ist, damit eine Karte zertifiziert bleibt, ist, dass keine Angriffe gegen diese Karte bekannt sind. Das heißt, wenn der Hersteller versehentlich diese Karte, also diese Chip, die im Perso ist, auch bei Druckerpatronen oder bei TPMs oder TPTV hatte, und plötzlich ist da ein Angriff bekannt geworden, kann der Angreifer plötzlich oder verliert der Hersteller diese Karte seine Zertifizierung und darf nicht mehr in deutsche Personalausweise integriert werden.
Also das ist unter anderem ein Grund, dass wir nicht nur einen Chiphersteller für die Personalausweise und Pässe haben, sondern zwei. Das heißt, wenn einer irgendwie ausfällt oder gehackt wird, dass man immer noch sagen kann, dann schenken wir jetzt mal schnell auf den anderen um für die nächsten 10.000 Personalausweise.
Micha, hat das deine Frage beantwortet?
Ja, du kannst die Daten aus, also du kannst zum Beispiel das Gesichtsbild auslesen, wenn du halt die Maschinedisparation hast. Also der Schlüssel für das Aussehen des Gesichtsbildes ist irgendwie auf dem E-Perso und der E-Pass aufgedruckt. Aber um halt die Fingerabdruckbilder auszulesen, brauchst du tatsächlich Zertifikate, die nur Grenzbeamte und Meldestellenbeamte haben. Also da kommst du nicht so einfach ran.
Okay, vielleicht können wir noch ein bisschen allgemein draufkommen, wie ich mich so gegen Hardware-Hacks und so ein bisschen schützen kann.
Das hat sich bis jetzt glaube ich viel schwierig angehört, aber vielleicht kann man dazu gleich noch ein Wort verlieren. Micha, vielen Dank für die Frage. Und viel Spaß noch. So, dann machen wir jetzt wie gesagt erstmal die Nachrichten. Und dann in der letzten halben Stunde beschäftigen wir uns noch ein bisschen mit den sogenannten Seitenkanal-Attacken. Aber dazu dann gleich mehr.
Hey Mann, unter den ganz großen Shootingstars ist John Newman noch relativ neu, Mann.
Ritz präsentiert.
Mittwoch, 5. März. Schon echt groß, aber immer noch neu, man.
John Newman präsentiert von.
Die Ukraine hat den Internationalen Währungsfonds offiziell um Hilfe gebeten. Angeblich steht das Land kurz vor dem Mangrot. Der Finanzbedarf für die kommenden Jahre wird auf umgerechnet 35 Milliarden Euro geschätzt. Der gestürzte Präsident Janukovic will sich laut Medienberichten morgen auf einer Pressekonferenz äußern. Er hält sich offenbar in Russland auf. Bereits heute erklärte er, dass er seine Absetzung nicht akzeptiert. Der Prozess gegen den ehemaligen Bundespräsidenten Wolf und den mit angeklagten Filmproduzenten Gronewald ist mit Freisprüchen zu Ende gegangen. Das Gericht erklärt in seiner Urteilsbegründung, ein strafbares Verhalten habe beiden nicht nachgewiesen werden können. Wolf sagte, das Recht habe sich durchgesetzt. Laut Anklage hatte er sich bei möglichen Sponsoren für ein Filmprojekt eingesetzt, weil Gronewald einen Oktoberfestbesuch von Wolf zum Teil bezahlt hatte. Die Staatsanwaltschaft will in der kommenden Woche entscheiden, ob sie Revisionen einlegt. Nutzer des Internetkonzerns Yahoo! sind offenbar jahrelang vom britischen Geheimdienst GCHQ ausspieniert worden. Der Guardian berichtet, dass zwischen 2008 und 2010 wahllos Standbilder von Videochats mit der Webcam gespeichert wurden. Betroffen seien etwa 1, 8 Millionen Nutzer. Der Geheimdienst habe danach versucht, die Personen per Gesichtserkennung zu identifizieren. Das stehen Unterlagen des Informanten Snowden. Eintracht Frankfurt ist in der Zwischenrunde der Fußball Europa League ausgeschieden. Gegen den FC Porto spielten die Hessen 3 zu 3 unentschieden. Aufgrund des Hinspiels ist Frankfurt damit aber trotzdem draußen. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Hellersdorf 3 und in Rheiningen-Dorf 8 Grad. Neuglobso 4, Bad Freienwalde 5, Cottbus 6 und Potsnam 7 Grad. In der Nacht ist es überall ziemlich wolkig, Regen ist aber die Ausnahme. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 4 bis plus 1 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wolkig, später lockert es etwas auf bei 8 bis 11 Grad. Mit einer Meldung in Berlin, Tunneltiergarten, ist bis Reich-Peach-Ufer zwischen Invalidenstraße und George C. Marshall Brücke nach einem Unfall gesperrt. Ansonsten rollt es euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit.
Naja, eine halbe haben wir noch hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um Hardware-Hacking geht. Wir haben schon viel gelernt über Chips aufschleifen, zum Beispiel in der letzten halben Stunde. Ihr könnt den Podcast auch nachhören, wenn euch das alles interessiert. Gibt es diese Nacht noch auf fritz.de, ansonsten auch auf chaosradio.ttc.de. So, zu Gast sind zum Beispiel Thorsten, Dimitri und Starbucks, der gerade unter dem Tisch verschwunden ist. Ich weiß auch nicht genau, was da los ist. Ich würde jetzt gerne zu dem Punkt kommen, was wird denn hier gelacht? Es gibt da zu lachen. Die Rolls-Royce-Bataste. Den wir am Anfang schon mal kurz angesprochen hatten, die sogenannten Seitenkanal-Attacken. Was genau heißt es eigentlich?
Also für Leute, die überhaupt in Hardware-Hacking einsteigen wollen, sind Seitenkanal-Angriffe ein sehr interessanter und zugänglicher, weil man dafür nicht so viele Gerätschaften braucht, wie wir in der Sendung erwähnt haben.
Also Seitenkanal-Angriffe. Normalerweise tut Chip irgendwas, um seine cryptografischen Funktionen durchzuführen. Dabei tut er noch was anderes, was man von außen angucken kann. Er verbraucht Strom und anhand dieses Stromverbrauchs kann man ermitteln, was er tatsächlich intern tut.
Also das heißt, man beobachtet Dinge, die jetzt gar nichts direkt mit dem Betrieb von Software zu tun haben.
Genau, Seiteneffekte, die man ausnutzt. Randeffekte, um dann zu schließen auf das, was da gerade passiert ist.
Und da gibt es die diversen, zum Beispiel magnetische Strahlung, elektromagnetische Strahlung oder den Stromverbrauch oder Photonaussendung. Also ich finde da tatsächlich Photonaussendung eines der coolsten Beispiele und da sind wir auch gleich wieder bei der Rückseite.
Bei der Rückseite vom Chip, über die wir schon gesprochen haben?
Genau, das ist einer der Angriffe, die Dmitry auch in seiner Deskortation beschreiben wird oder beschreibt. Also Seitenkanäle. Dieser Chip tut ja was, er hat da Transistoren, die ihn hin und her schalten, um den Programmcode auszuführen. Nun ist es so, dass so ein Transistor, wenn er schaltet, in ganz geringem Maße auch Photonen aussendet. Das heißt, wieder flitzen Elektronen rum, die zur Funktion des Transistors beitragen und ab und zu wird so ein Elektron in so ein Photon umgewandelt. Das heißt Licht. Ein Lichtteilchenwelle, du alles musst. Was man jetzt tun kann, ist, man guckt durch die Rückseite diesen Transistoren zu, wie sie praktisch arbeiten. Das heißt, du hast dort eine Kamera, die relativ...
Günstig ist. Na doch, wir haben das auch mit Kameras gemacht, die empfindlich ist.
Also die halt tatsächlich so einzelne Photonen mehr oder weniger aufnehmen kann.
Reden wir da wieder von einem halben Millionen Dollar Gerät?
Nö, wir sind da auf jeden Fall im wenigen 1000 Euro Bereich.
3000 bis 5000 Euro. Also was man eigentlich in der Regel tut, wenn man wirklich solche Seidenkanne-Angriffe machen möchte, ist, man kauft aus dem Astronomie-Bereich einer Kamera und die passende Mikroskop-Optik dazu. Also das Gewinde ist standardisiert, also kann man auch ein Mikroskop-Objektiv da dran schrauben. Und Astronomie ist so populär, dass man billig Infrarot-Kameras kaufen kann.
Das haben wir noch nicht dazu gesagt, also das geht halt in dem Fall um Infrarot-Licht, dass man sich anguckt und deswegen ist es auch ganz toll, dass man sich durch die Rückseite anguckt, weil Silizium, also das Triggermaterial für Infrarot-Licht durchsichtig ist. Das heißt, man sieht halt tatsächlich von hinten diesen Transistoren. Also das ist halt der Sinn von diesen Seitenkanälen, dass du halt die aktive, also die normale Funktion dieses Transistors ist, dass er irgendwie schaltet, blablabla. Und zusätzlich macht er halt ab und zu mal noch was anderes. Und das andere, was er tut, ist halt dieses Photon-Aussenden, womit man dann halt im Endeffekt tatsächlich Schaltvorgänge sichtbar machen kann. Also das heißt, du kannst tatsächlich sagen, zu welchem Zeitpunkt, zu welchen Transistoren gerade geschaltet haben oder welcher Speicherbereich gerade ausgelesen wurde. Und wenn man das tun kann, dann hat man natürlich ein Feld von Informationen, womit man sozusagen den gesamten Chip mehr oder weniger blank vor sich liegen hat. Also dass man ihm alles extrahieren kann.
Und dann muss man so sagen, muss man gar nichts mehr reinstecken, aufschneiden, sondern man macht einfach nur das Licht aus und die Kamera an.
Im Endeffekt ist das genau so, ja.
Das ist ja großartig. Gibt es noch mehr? Das hört sich nach einem spannenden Bereich an. Also ich habe zum Beispiel, oder andersrum, Frage. Ich habe neulich gehört, man kann Chips dabei zuhören, wie sie Kryptografie entschlüsseln.
Genau.
Und zwar indem man ein Handy daneben legt.
Genau. Also das wurde auch letztens gezeigt, dass es tatsächlich machbar ist. Also es gibt tatsächlich, abhängig von der Berechnung, die gerade auf dem Chip stattfindet, kann man von der, von, man kennt auch dieses Effekt mit dem, mit, wenn ein Handy klingelt, hört man plötzlich durch die Autolautsprecher, wie das Handy klingelt. Also gibt es Frequenzen, die irgendwie auch im hörbaren Bereich sind. Und genauso ist das auch mit der Kryptographie teilweise. Da wird auch ein sehr geringer Teil sozusagen von den Frequenzen, abhängig von der Berechnung, hört man auch. Und das heißt, wenn man, je nachdem, was man für Frequenzen hört und von der Amplitude, also von der Stärke, von der Lautstärke der Frequenzen, kann man tatsächlich die einzelnen Nullen zurückrechnen. Also Dmitry praktisch die Schlüssel. Genau, in den Fällen, man sollte das auch erwähnen, das ist auch ein Grund, warum man heutzutage Kryptographie in hohen Sicherheitssystemen, in Hardware tatsächlich realisiert, weil man da solche Problematiken viel besser unter Kontrolle hat, wenn man sie tatsächlich als Transistoren realisiert und nicht mehr als Software.
Also wir wollten ja coole Beispiele bringen, die irgendwie für Seitenkanäle, wo man jetzt mal ein bisschen vom Chip weggeht und so ein bisschen anschaulicher und greifbarer hat, eine Tastatur. Eine Tastatur dient dazu, irgendwie deinen Key einzutippen, irgendwie deiner Freundin zu schreiben und was auch immer. Was die Tastatur tut, ist sie sendet auch Geräusche aus, wenn du auf den Tasten rauf rumhaust. Was es jetzt als Seitenkanal gibt oder als Seitenkanal Angriff gibt, du hast ein Telefon, dich ruft jemand an, du legst irgendwie dein Handy oder dein Hörer neben das Telefon, redest mit ihm, während du tippst. Er sagt dir, gib mal dein Passwort ein, tippst dein Passwort auf die Tastatur ein. Die Tastaturanschläge selber verraten dem am anderen Ende des Telefons sitzenden, welche Tasten du gerade gedrückt hast. Weil halt jede Taste ein bisschen anders klingt, wenn man sie drückt. Das ist halt so ein klassischer Seitenkanal über Audio, wo man halt tatsächlich so ganz einfache Sachen extrahieren kann, wie ein Passwort.
Um das Beispiel weiterzuführen, es gab auch ein sehr schönes Paper, dass jeder Smartphone heutzutage ein Gyroskop drauf hat. Und je nachdem, wie das gerade in der Hand liegt, und wie man auf der Tastatur, die auf dem Bildschirm ist, draufdrückt, kann man anhand der Beschleunigung, also der Bewegung, wie man sozusagen auf dem Handy getippt hat und wie es sich ein bisschen verdreht hat, weil man mit dem Finger aufgedrückt hat, auch die Tastendrücke, also die Tasteneingaben auf dem Bildschirm zurückrechnen. Aber da gibt es jede Menge Beispiele. Also vielleicht das anschaulichste und einfachste ist ein sogenanntes Timing-basiertes Seitenkanal-Angriff, der, bin ich mir sicher, auch in vielen Geräten noch zu finden sein wird, die Leute um sich herumliegen haben, nämlich die Pin-Eingabe. Und oft ist es so, dass wenn man, also wenn man selber viele, also viel programmiert hat, kennt man das, dass wenn man das sozusagen in den Code schreibt, wird man nach jedem Tastendruck, wird man sozusagen, wird das Programm schauen, ob das gestimmt hat oder nicht. Und man kann tatsächlich ausmessen, wie schnell das Programm reagiert hatte und daraus zurückrechnen, ob das gerade eine gültige oder ungültige Ziffer-Eingabe war.
Sind wir dann noch wie beim Geldautomaten, ich drücke eine Ziffer, also ich gebe meine PIN-Nummer an, und je nachdem, wie schnell der piep kommt, weiß ich dann im Prinzip schon, ob es gerade richtig oder falsch war. Und dann kann ich sozusagen anfangen, die PIN-Nummer zu raten. Und vorhin habe ich ja schon gelernt, wenn ich den Stromzufuhr des Geldautomaten kontrolliere, kann ich dann auch verhindern, dass der Sperr nicht so oft falsch gerannt ist.
Stark vereinfacht dargestellt.
Klar, stark vereinfacht dargestellt, aber dann braucht man nicht mehr so viele Versuche, weil ich meine, es gibt nur zehn Ziffern und die erste habe ich dann relativ schnell raus.
Und dann die zweite und dann die vierte. Also wenn du es halt nicht mehr zehntausendmalst versuchen, sondern tatsächlich dann pro Stelle zehnmal.
Da wäre übrigens eine Gegenmaßnahme, die auch tatsächlich angewandt wird von den Programmierern dieser Software in diesen Chips, dass man eben auch zufällige Delays einbaut zwischen verschiedenen Tastendrücken.
Also das wäre halt eine mögliche Maßnahme, um so eine zeitbasierten Side-Channel-Angriffe oder tatsächlich erst mal komplett die vierstellige Pinneneingabe abwartet und dann halt diese gesamte Vierstelligzahl einmal vergleicht und nicht halt jede Ziffer einzeln.
Am Ende ist das wieder irgendwie ein Programmierfehler, also nicht zu Ende gedacht.
Genau, wir kommen doch nicht von der Software ganz weg.
Ärgerlich.
Jetzt gibt es hier noch in der Liste von Dingen, die für mich interessant klingen, den Stichpunkt Sensoren täuschen.
Also für mich, ich dachte, das würde für mich in die Kategorie fallen. Ich glaube, zumindest so wie ich Sensoren verstanden habe, waren das auch die Angriffssensoren, die wir als Gegenmaßnahmen erwähnt haben. Aber ich meine, nur um dieses Beispiel ein bisschen nochmal vielleicht anders darzustellen, ist eigentlich auch das, was Thorsten vorhin sagte. Es geht auch, dass man auf einem Chip oder in einem Sicherheitssystem oder auf einem, sagen wir mal, nehmen wir mal an, man hat sowas wie ein iPhone, wo mittlerweile ein Fingerprint-Sensor ist. Man weiß ja nicht, von wo der Signal, also Apple sagt einem ja nicht, von wo der Signal ausgesendet wird, dass der Fingerabdruck anerkannt wurde. Es kann durchaus sein, dass das an irgendeiner Stelle passiert, sogar auf dem PCB vom iPhone, also auf der Platine, wo die ganzen Chips zusammenverdrahtet sind, dass man da sozusagen einen gültigen Fingerprint gegebenenfalls vortäuschen kann. Ich glaube nicht, dass Apple so gravierende Fehler gemacht hat, aber dieser Fehler mit den Zertifikaten war doch ziemlich schlecht.
Du meinst halt, um jetzt ausgeschaltet... Um es noch mal vereinfachter zu stellen, praktisch hinter der Vergleich ist der aktuelle Fingerabdruck mit dem der Datenbank gleich, dann ist ja irgendwie die Abfrage ja oder nein, dass man dahinter dieses eine Bit dann irgendwie umändert.
Okay, dann haben wir noch Sicherheit, die Sicherungen löschen, Fuses, das fand ich ganz gut, weil Sicherung kenne ich halt von zu Hause, wenn im Bad das Licht ausgeht, dann...
Stand da wirklich Sicherung in der Liste?
Es steht Fuses, das sind halt so Schutzmechanismen von Mikrocontrollern, die verhindern sollen, dass man bestimmte Daten aus so einem Chip oder aus dem Speicher wieder auslesen kann. Also wer sich mal mit Mikrocontrollern ein bisschen befasst hat, der weiß, dass man mit Programmieradaptern oder sonst was für Mechanismen eben seine programmierte Firmware in diesen Mikrocontroller reinflaschen kann. Also man speichert diesen Binaerkod auf diesem Chip und man kann ihn auch wieder auslesen. Und durch diese Fuses, also diese Sicherungen, kann man diesen Chip nochmal auf einem Niveau konfigurieren und Sicherheitsmaßnahmen aktivieren, die zum Beispiel verhindern, dass man diesen Code wieder auslesen kann. Weil wir wissen ja, dass Hacker, die irgendwelche Geräte und Gadgets, die sich anschauen wollen, die wollen vor allen Dingen versuchen, an diese Firmware zu kommen, also an diese Binary Files. Und dafür setzt man dann eben diese Fuses, dass es auf dem einfachen Wege eben nicht möglich ist. Das heißt, man muss dann eben schon wieder einen sehr viel höheren Aufwand betreiben, um diesen Schutzmechanismus noch auszuhebeln oder zu umgehen. Und da gibt es eben auch entsprechend Möglichkeiten, diese Fuses neu zu konfigurieren. Und da gibt es halt ja, das können halt Implementierungsfehler sein in der Logik, dass man vielleicht den Chip selber nicht mal kaputt machen muss oder aufmachen muss, um dann dort, was ich, mit bestimmtem Licht auch noch reinzuleuchten. Aber eben Hardware-seitige Angriffe gegen diese Chips, um halt einmalig an diese Firmware ranzukommen. Da gibt es halt einige Mechanismen, die sich ja Dmitry auch besser beschreiben kann, weil er das halt häufiger tut.
Also bei der Hardware kann man sagen, mit einem FIP geht das auf jeden Fall immer. Also du kannst einfach mit so einem FIP alles machen und dann so einen Kanon auf den Spatzen schießen.
Bei Fuses finde ich auch sehr interessant oder ist ein interessantes Beispiel dafür, dass auch viele, also Fuses sind in der Regel etwas, wo du vom Werk aus einmalig, also es gibt auch Fuses, wo man sie mehrmals überschreiben kann, aber es gibt auch einmalige Fuses und einmalige Fuses werden oft benutzt, um beispielsweise pro Karte einen anderen Schlüssel zu speichern. Also in der PTV-Karte zum Beispiel ist es oft so, dass der Schlüssel, der diese Karte eigentlich enthält, in Fuses gespeichert wird. Und genauso bei Xbox oder Wii und sonst was.
Also ein einmalig Schreiben heißt in dem Fall, dass sie durch hohen Strom anlegen, die Sicherung durchbrennen lassen. Also wie eine normale Sicherung, da wird einfach Strom angelegt, dann ist es durchgebrannt, das repräsentiert dann eine Null, wenn es nicht durchgebrannt ist, ist es eine Eins.
Und was man dann tun kann, ist, wenn man diese Stelle identifiziert hat auf dem Chip, kann man tatsächlich auch mit einer Probing-Nadel dahin gehen und den Ausgang des Fuses, also wo die Logik, wo die Eins oder Null aus diesem Fus rausfällt, kann man sie treiben. Und man kann zum Beispiel, indem man einen hohen Strom anlegt, also nicht einen hohen Strom, sondern eine Versorgungsspannung, also eine Eins legt man an, kann man dafür sorgen, also man weiß ja, man treibt immer, man ist immer als Angreifer stärker als die Karte selber und man weiß, dass da auf der Schaltung eine Eins vorliegt, wenn man mit der Probing-Nadel da drauf sitzt. Das heißt, man kann dann alle Bits, also alle Schlüssel-Bits des alle Fuses durchgehen und da einfach mal sagen, jetzt will ich, dass du eine Eins treibst. Und was man dabei tut, ist, man schaut, also wo wir jetzt zurück bei, also wo wir wieder bei Seitenkanoneingriffen sind, man guckt, ob der, ob die Nachricht, die man aus der Karte bekommt, sich verändert hat. Weil wenn sie sich verändert hat, weiß man, dass ein Bild gekippt ist. Und da man weiß, dass das Bild auf eins gesetzt worden ist, wenn es sich gekippt hat, weiß man, dass es eine Null vorher hat.
So kann man das sagen, dann langsam rausfinden. Jetzt wissen wir, was man alles machen kann, das ist durchaus spannend. Und ich weiß, ob es jetzt nur, also klar, es gibt diese, also Druckerpatronen kann man täuschen für Autos, vielleicht interessant. Aber die großen Sachen sind, also Pay-TV, da ist es ganz wichtig und beim E-Pay, sozusagen ein politisches Ding, kann man sagen. Ist Hardware-Hacking jetzt eher so eine spannende Kategorie, weil es da so viel zu erleben gibt, wenn man sie erstmal beschäftigt, oder ist das tatsächlich in unserem persönlichen Alltag wird das auch irgendwie wichtig? Oder wie Michael es gefragt hat, kann man sich vor sowas überhaupt schützen? Oder muss man sich überhaupt vor sowas schützen? Oder bin ich als normaler User eigentlich eher das Ziel von Softwareangriffen?
Also was man vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang sagen muss, wenn es halt eine Schwäche in der Software gibt, dann kann man ein Update anspielen. Das heißt, wie bei Apple jetzt gerade, wartet man halt ein paar Tage, klickt dann auf Update. Oder ein paar Tage länger.
Oder anderthalb Jahre.
Klickt dann auf Update und dann ist das Problem gelöst. Bei Hardware ist es halt nicht so einfach zu machen. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, ich verdrate jetzt die Transistoren neu. In der Regel ist bei Hardware so, dass du dann tatsächlich den kompletten Chip oder das komplette System tatsächlich auswechseln musst.
In PTV sieht es so aus, dass man tatsächlich eine neue Karte bekommt von seinem PTV-Anbieter. Also wenn sie rausfinden, dass es kopierte Karten im Umlauf sind, wenn sie abschätzen, wie viele Karten das tatsächlich sind und wenn es zu viele sind, dass sie viel zu große Verluste dadurch machen, schicken sie einfach jedem, der tatsächlich sein Fernsehen bezahlt, eine neue Karte, die dann wiederum diese Schwachstelle nicht mehr hat.
Und das zeigt einfach mal, um wie viel das Geld da geht. Also ich meine, so eine Karte kostet halt schon so ein paar Euro, irgendwie 5, 6 Euro oder so was und mal 100.000 oder ein paar Millionen irgendwie Zuschauer. Das heißt, da ist schon einfach mal echt viel Geld zu machen, sowohl für die Piraten als auch Geld zu verlieren für die Hersteller.
Also ich halte fest, woanders spielt das anscheinend keine große Rolle in unserem alltäglichen Leben.
Na also P-TV ist auf jeden Fall tatsächlich so das Treiben, da ist am meisten passiert in der Vergangenheit.
Also für mich ist das einfach, wo die Gewinne, die sich die Piraten in dem Sinne aus P-TV rausschlagen können, sind am größten. Also heutzutage, würde ich sagen, wenn man das mit den Druckerpatronen beobachtet, ist es interessant zu sehen, dass es auch in anderen Gebieten so weitergeht.
Also ich denke mal, wegversperre ist irgendwie das zweite Beispiel.
Ich denke, das ist halt auch irgendwie so ein Markt, wo so ein Research am Ende auch durch Produktverkauf wieder zurückfinanziert wird. Also dass eben Leute sich die ganzen Krypto-Algorithmen in den Autoschlüsseln anschauen und wie man diese Wegfahrsperren umgehen kann. Und sowas wird dann am Ende auf dem Schwarzmarkt verkauft, sodass eben irgendwelche Autodiebe das leichter haben, diese Autos aufzumachen und schnell aufzumachen, ohne dass Alarm ausgelöst wird und so weiter. Also ich denke, das ist halt auch nochmal so ein, das wird bestimmt in Zukunft, wird uns das häufiger begegnen, dass uns diese ganzen elektronischen Geräte, auf die wir uns verlassen müssen, nochmal auf die Füße fallen. Also da, wo wirklich auch Geld dann eine Rolle spielt. Autos, Pay-TV, das wird immer so bleiben. Identitätsdiebstahl ist irgendwie eines der größten Probleme, mit denen im Internet halt auch zu kämpfen ist. Und das wird natürlich begünstigt dadurch, wenn wir irgendwann mal Schwachstellen in unseren Personalausweisen finden, die sich eben ausnutzen lassen, um die Dinger zu klonen, um die Identität zu stehlen. Ja, das ist halt noch nicht so besonders akut, aber ich denke, das kann man schon so sagen.
Aber Markus hat das Beispiel mit Autoersatzteilen sehr gut gefallen.
Überall da, wo die Hersteller vor allem durch Lizenzierungsgebühren auch Geld verdienen. Das ist bei den Druckerpatronen halt so. Das ist ja nicht, dass diese Patrone 80 Euro kostet, weil das Zeug so teuer ist, sondern weil das ist halt so... Die verkaufen billige Drucker und wollen mit den Druckerpatronen nachher das Geld machen. Und bei Autos wird das auch so sein. Das heißt, die einzelnen Komponenten, die in so einem modernen Auto verbaut werden, die authentifizieren sich so gegeneinander, dass sie ja so sicher sein können, ich spreche jetzt hier wirklich mit einem Bauteil von Hersteller XY und alles andere wird halt verworfen. Also das wird dann nicht akzeptiert, sodass man eben immer Originalersatzteile kaufen muss.
Also das ist zu sagen, das ist...
Kundenbindung.
Das ist Kopierschutz für Dinge.
Genau.
Und sagen die Software-Piraten, also die Hardware-Piraten sozusagen, sind dann die Leute, die Hardware-Hacking machen, um diese Authentifizierung von Dingen zu umgehen.
Genau. Und dann gibt es Leute, die gehen damit dann an den CCC-Kongress und machen einen lustigen Talk drüber. Und dann gibt es auch Leute, die gehen damit nach China und bauen eben Geräte, die das Ganze dann...
Originalteile. Kaufen sie Originalteile. Hardware-Hacking war das. Sehr spannend, sehr interessant. Vielen Dank an Starbucks, Dmitry und Thorsten, die sich da zwei Stunden Zeit genommen haben, um das zu erklären. Ihr könnt diese Sendung auch noch mal nachhören. In allen Details auf fritz.de wird der Podcast heute Nacht erscheinen, im Laufe der Woche sicherlich auch unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Und zum Schluss gibt es noch ein paar Termine und News, die die Herren euch mitteilen wollen. Bitte schön, bitte schön.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Liste... Ich hab hier zwei Termine, auf die ich noch hinweisen wollte, weil die halt in der nächsten Zeit anstehen.
Über das 30C3 wurde schon mal gesprochen in der letzten Sendung, oder? Aber jetzt sind auf jeden Fall alle Videos im Internet. Die sollte man sich alle anfangen.
Stimmt, ich muss noch Videos gucken.
Wenn ihr z.B. den Talk von Dmitry sehen wollt, der genau über dieses Ding noch mal in ganzer Sprache hat, das kann man sich z.B. antun. Und es gibt auf der Website jetzt alle Talks in allen, nicht in allen Sprachen, aber sozusagen in Bild und Ton. Was waren die noch, die beiden Termine?
Wir haben im Ostern natürlich wieder die Easter Hack. Die findet vom 18. bis zum 21. April in Stuttgart statt. Und da kann man sich ja jetzt schon mal langsam bemühen, sich die Reise und was ich etwaige vorträge, die man vortragen möchte, vorzubereiten.
Was ist Easter Hack ganz kurz?
Das ist eine kleine Veranstaltung.
Das ist der Deckung Rest in Klein. Also sehr gemütlich, ein paar hundert Leute, nette Lokalität.
Aber ein Stück.
Und die Camping-Fanatiker unter euch freuen sich sicherlich über das Camp++, das im letzten Jahr unter dem Namen Camp Zero stattfand, und zwar in Ungarn. Das ist zwar noch eine Weile hin, das findet vom 21.8. bis 24.8. im Fort Monostor in Komarom Ungarn statt. Und das erwähne ich vor allen Dingen deshalb, weil dort auch noch eine Submission Deadline für Talks besteht, die dann am 1.4. abläuft. Das heißt, wer gerne auf einem sehr gemütlichen Camp auch mal etwas vortragen möchte, der sollte sich das mal anschauen.
In Englisch aber wahrscheinlich dann.
Ich denke schon. Ich könnte die URL jetzt vorlesen. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht pack ich die einfach in den IRC für das Protokoll, oder?
Genau, das können wir auch in den Blogpost zur Sendung machen, zur nächsten.
Ich habe mir das heute mal erklären und zeigen lassen. Und das sieht schon nach einem wirklich netten Event aus. Also zumindest auch die Umgebung macht einen sehr netten Eindruck.
Also im Sommer mal draußen sitzen und trotzdem hacken.
Gibt es da auch Internet?
Ich vermute.
Fahrt hin und findet es selber raus. Liebe Leute, liebe Kinder, lieber Hörerinnen, das war das Chaosradio Nummer 198. Wir übergehen an dieser Stelle an Flo Heiler, der euch im Night Flight. Ich vermute, es wird Musik, in der Stromgitarren vorkommen sein. Nur so eine Vermutung. Woher weißt du das? Unglaublich. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich verabschiede mich und mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.